you know these magic mic movies teach me
one important lesson I got a long way to
go
there we are Magic Mike xx and yeah I
work out in the suit
what of it so Magic Mike XXL is the
sequel to the surprisingly good Magic
Mike the movie I went into thinking it
was gonna be a cliche male stripper
movie made for one purpose to make those
Cougars feel young again but I had a
surprisingly good story about a kid who
gets wrapped up in that world it has
surprisingly good characters Channing
Tatum had hopes and dreams he was
reaching for bigger things and now Magic
Mike XXL continues that tradition of
other cliche male stripper movies that
exist for one reason to make Cougars
feel young again
seriously I'm watching this movie and
I'm like where's the magic where's the
magic in the Mike McConaughey is not
back in this movie that's not a big deal
the kid the main kid from the first
movie he's not back in this movie that's
really not a big deal his from PS sister
is not in this movie that's a good thing
Thank You Magic Mike XXL but ultimately
in Magic Mike XXL Mike has been gone
from the gang for about three years he
gets back together with him because
they're going on a road trip to these
super stripper finals or some so
really that's what we have we have a
road trip movie and not a really
interesting one at that I'm not asking
for all the stripper although when
it does go down you can't help but
appreciate the form and go you know
that's a damn impressive
like I said got a long way to go and
they make their pit stops in this place
and that place so you can see more
stripper jerseys about when they
get to Jada Pinkett Smith's place and
stripping starts happening but it's not
with the characters you know it's these
people that you've never met before and
they start stripping and it concentrates
on the stripping for a really long time
that's what I was like this movie does
exist for one reason and that's to make
every assure in every movie theater
showing Magic Mike XXL regret his job
and know that he's gonna go into an
auditorium full of seats that smell like
stale spam and feel like a teddy bear
that's left in the storm drain too long
that is why we're here I'm not saying
there weren't moments in this movie
there are more than a few moments of
good dialogue most of which had to do
with Channing Tatum the dude continues
to impress me he's a good actor I like
him some of the other crew had their
moments to shine there's a subtle
message in this movie oh where do we go
after this and that's always good to
know in a movie like this but a couple
of the characters from the first movie
returning in this movie felt like
cartoon versions of themselves
everything Magic Mike was reaching for
in the first movies totally gone in this
movie now he just has stripping the
intrigue the peak bhai
curtain from the first movie nowhere in
this movie so if you're looking for the
magic in the mic that was in the first
movie not here but a few Cougars out
there looking for a fun movie to go out
in the town with your girlfriends well
you're rocking you're on the prowl
t-shirt and your friend Betty has her
over for tea and feeling foxy t-shirt
this is yours but for me I'm gonna say
I'm not gonna remember Magic Mike in
t-minus one day ya already forgot it
does make you want to work out though
got a long way to go
that's for sure so Magic Mike XXL have
you not seen it what did you not think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know I'd have a conundrum
there I know and as always if you liked
what you've seen here and you wanna see
more click right here to see more